in an op-ed on foxnews.com former
Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich he
wrote quote if not judge Kavanagh then
who this is the question Republicans
need to ask themselves as they prepare
for Thursday Senate Judiciary Committee
hearing joining us now is new gamers
don't forget by the way his new book
Trump's America it's available now part
two of which talks about all the
challenges the president will face Mr
Speaker I want you look at the fact
Dianne Feinstein had this literally had
this in July she didn't bring it up till
now then the people that Professor Ford
mentioned all of them deny it and then
you got the New Yorker article where mr.
Ramirez admit she was inebriated very
early slurring her words gaps in her
merit memory etc and then you have the
new face of the Democratic Party says
all I'm going to reveal gang-raped by in
the next 48 hours I don't know what what
are the American people to think and so
many Democrats rushing to judgment no
presumption of innocence look I think
what the American people should think is
that you have a Democratic Party so
desperate to stop the Supreme Court from
becoming conservative that they are
prepared to lie to smear to be
hysterical to break Senate rules to do
whatever they have to do what you're
watching is a party totally desperate
and and you've got to put this week in
context I I was struck earlier today
that Arthur Miller is great play The
Crucible which is about the Salem
Witchcraft Trials Axia relates to what's
happening to judge Cavanaugh what he's
being put through is almost like a
medieval torture somebody shows up 35
years later everybody in the audience
start to think about this close your
eyes for a second and ask what were you
doing on June 12th 35 years ago the
truth is you almost certainly don't know
and the fact is this hearing is a farce
there's nothing that Cavanaugh can say
which will convince Chuck Shumer to vote
for him and I think that dr. Ford has no
evidence other than her own word which
is going to count
she can't they can't provide any
witnesses
she can't even tell us to the best of my
knowledge what was the date where was
the house who all were there the people
she names I'll say they weren't there
now at what point is the burden of
common-sense on the accuser and if it's
a burden of common sense this hearing
wouldn't even be held it's only in the
current hyper environment in which
senator Hirono can say men ought to just
shut up I mean think about the level of
venom in that sentence
you have an entire effort by the
totalitarian left to to bludgeon us you
saw it last night as you reported with
senator Cruz and his wife I mean what
has happened to America when random
left-wing to tolet Aryans think they can
violate private property trespass in a
restaurant who in an intimidate a
citizen who's simply trying to have
dinner and they think they're heroes and
apparently the police aren't called
nobody's arrested for trespass nobody's
arrested for intimidation
we are watching a period where what we
ought to understand is this is about raw
power and if the left hand stopped
Cavanaugh we will not get another
conservative justice in our lifetime on
the Supreme Court you talk about his for
decades as an exemplary husband father
friend judges bent over 220 people that
have come out and said this guy is a cut
above a gentleman's gentleman and that
I'm listening to these lawmakers many of
them when they say I believe in the case
of Professor corridor I believe mr.
Ramirez but they're really saying is
they don't want to hear anything they
don't believe in due process they don't
believe in the presumption of innocence
and I got to be honest how does
lawmakers say he has to prove his
innocence we've had lawmakers say that
senator Coons said he has to prove his
innocence from 40 years ago 36 years oh
look look there's a whole block of
left-wing Democrats whether it's Coons
or it's Schumer or it's a variety of
other people on the Left they're
hopeless they have no interest in the
truth they're involved in a struggle
over power they've got to pay off their
activists base there there's no
possibility that they're going to vote
for judge Kavanagh but what I am
fascinated with is let's say you're the
senator from West Virginia or Missouri
or Indiana or North Dakota or Montana
now you're from an area where there are
a lot of common sense everyday folks who
like Donald Trump who believe Donald
Trump's doing the right thing who want
to have a more conservative Court let's
say you the newly the junior senator
from Alabama do you really want to line
up with Chuck Schumer and the left away
with Booker and his pathetic portrait of
Spartacus which as a historian I found
particularly offensive II clearly had no
idea who Spartacus was I think these
senators who are from states where
there's a lot of common sense a lot of
conservatism a desire for more can sort
of judges we have not heard a single one
of them yet and I will be very surprised
if we don't have a number of them vote
yes remember when when the Clarence
Thomas character assassination was under
way 11 Democrats ended up voting YES for
Clarence Thomas and I think we may find
all of a sudden once you through
Thursday there's several these Democrats
from Trump States decide in the end you
know she didn't prove her case I'm gonna
vote yes he deserves to be on the court
he also has a 40-year track record I
think your observation is Right 42 days
in the election now I can tell you that
people that I hear from three hours a
day on radio and watch this show they
are angry because instinctively
Americans believe in due process they
believe in fundamental fairness they
don't believe in a rush to judgment we
have seen in high-profile cases Duke
Lacrosse Ferguson Missouri
Baltimore Freddie gray Trayvon Martin
Cambridge police we've seen a lot of
rushing to judgment where a lot of the
same people have been wronged again and
again but as far as the Republicans go
it seems like it's coming down for
people for them and they have control of
this
that would be bob Corker that would be
Jeff Flake I think susan collins
probably had the best comment of anybody
saying with Diane finds things it is
unfair to everybody in this case and
Lisa Murkowski I don't know what to
expect from any of them tonight well I
don't need that I mean I think Thursday
is important only in the sense that
unless dr. Ford is overwhelmingly
convincing and unless Judge Cavanaugh is
overwhelmingly disappointing I suspect
all four of the Republicans will end up
deciding that there is no case adequate
to say no at the same time I believe as
I just said that there are five or six
Democrats who are on the bubble who have
to go home and explain why they voted
with with Schumer and why they voted
with Warren and why they voted with
Booker and I think that this could be a
very expensive vote in terms of
defeating five or six or seven Democrats
because I think their states are going
to say to them you know there's no proof
here that justifies voting no on judge
Kavanagh all right Mr Speaker we
appreciate your time sorry you couldn't
make it here you're in DC but you
wouldn't even come see us and we're
outside and the Capitol bind is
beautiful that's where you tell you is
know all I tell you is Calista had a
better offer Wow
all right I don't blame her I don't
blame you a good choice good to see you
sir thank you